on retrouve gulliver craag notre
correspondant à kiev l armée russe
semble connaître des difficultés
notamment autour de la capitale mais
quelle est la part réelle de ces
difficultés et quelle est la part de
maîtrise stratégique
alors là pentagone a confirmé que
l'armée russe avait reculé d'une
trentaine de kilomètres en direction est
de la capitale de kiev ça c'est donc une
direction uniquement pour les autres
directions nous avons les affirmations
des ukrainiens ils affirment avoir
repris le contrôle de macquarie il
semble que les confrères de france 2 ont
pu le constater de leurs propres yeux
pourrir pin c'est plus difficile les
ukrainiens dit avoir pris le contrôle
d'au moins 80% de la ville c'est une
ville satellite de kiev situe à environ
17 km du centre-ville en direction nord
ouest mais j'ai parlé tout à l'heure à
un habitant irvine qui m'a dit que la
bataille continue et qu'il est trop tôt
pour affirmer vraiment que là où les
deux côtés alain côté ou l'autre soit
vraiment on contrôle de la ville moi
même j'avais l'impression depuis le
centre ville de kiev que j'entendais
moins de bruit venant de la direction
des ruines aujourd'hui mais c'est habite
on m'a dit que ce n'est pas le cas que
la bataille est plus ou moins tout aussi
intense qui hier et on lui parle au
téléphone j'entendais bien les prix de
l'artillerie derrière les nations unies
disent qu'il ya un risque de famine dans
toute l'ukraine notamment à marioupol
ville martyre qu'en est il
alors je pense que dire qu'il y aurait
un risque de famine dans tout le crâne
c'est clairement exagéré mais sur
marioupol oui il y as absolument un
grand danger beaucoup de gens la firme
un journaliste rescapés de marioupol que
là il a affirmé qu'il pense qu'il ya
déjà des gens qui sont morts de faim et
je pense que c'est hautement probable
parce que cela fait plus de trois
semaines que la ville n'a plat n'a pas
accès aux denrées alimentaires les
convois alimentaires humanitaires que
l'ukraine essaye à t'envoyer sont
bloqués par la russie les supermarchés
ont été bombardés la ville est
complètement contournée par les forces
russes qui ne laisse pas rentrer les
produits alimentaires dont la ville et
les gens sont pour la plupart cachés
dans des sous sols alors que les
bombardements sans presque constant donc
je pense que le risque qu'ils n'ont pas
assez il s'était absolument clair qu'ils
n'ont pas assez
vous avez aussi vu ces images je pense
qu'on a transmises sur france 24 de
cette que énorme de personnes qui ont
réussi à sortir de marioupol mais qui
maintenant faisait la queue pour acheter
de la nourriture on voit très bien
qu'ils ont très faim merci beaucoup
gilbert craag pour votre décryptage est
votre analyse merci à vous